STATIONED IN JAPAN.
MOLLY.
MOLLY:  ALARMING NEW RESEARCH
MAY TELL US WHY HOUSTON IS
SEEING SUCH A HIGH SPIKE IN
CORONAVIRUS CASES WITH HOUSTON’S
TEXAS MEDICAL CENTER REPORTEDLY
AT 105% CAPACITY.
RESEARCHERS AT BAYLOR COLLEGE OF
MEDICINE SAY A STRAIN OF THE
VIRUS IN THE AREA HAS MUTATED
AND HAS BECOME EVEN MORE
CONTAGIOUS THAN WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN SO FAR.
JOINING ME NOW, DR. CEDRIC DARK,
EMERGENCY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN AND
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT BAYLOR
COLLEGE OF MEDICINE, THE FOUNDER
OF POLICY PRESCRIPTION AND A
BOARD MEMBER OF DOCTORS FOR
AMERICA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH US
TODAY.
WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING A NUMBER
OF STATES THAT HAVE SEEN A SPIKE
IN CASES ALONG THE SUN BELT.
IF YOU COULD GIVE US INSIDE TO
START THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT YOU’RE SEEING IN TEXAS,
MORE SPECIFICALLY IN HOUSTON.
>> YESTERDAY WAS TEXAS’
DEADLIEST DAY OF THE PANDEMIC,
OVER 100 PEOPLE DIED.
AND I’VE SEEN REPORTS THAT
REFRIGERATED TRUCKS ARE COMING
INTO TEXAS TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE
BODIES BECAUSE THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH SPACES IN THE MORGUES.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
EXPERIENCED ONE OTHER TIME, BACK
WHEN I WAS IN MEDICAL SCHOOL,
2001, DURING 9/11.
I ACTUALLY WENT TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL IN NEW YORK AND FROM MY
14th FLOOR I COULD SEE ONTO
THE OFFICE OF THE CHIEF MEDICAL
EXAMINER AND I COULD SEE ROWS OF
REFRIGERATED TRUCKS, A WHITE
TARP THAT CARRIED THE BODIES OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE KILLED IN
THE COLLAPSE OF THE TWIN TOWERS.
BUT JUST TO PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE, MORE PEOPLE HAVE
DIED IN TEXAS FROM COVID THAN
THOSE WHO DIED DURING THE 9/11
ATTACKS.
MOLLY:  IT’S SOMETHING
PARTICULARLY SCARY BECAUSE WE’RE
HARDLY CLOSE TO THE END OF THIS
AT ALL.
AND NOW WE’RE SEEING THIS NEW
RESEARCH, SO THIS IS THE
NATIONAL LABORATORY, THEY
DISCOVERED A MUTATION OF THE
VIRUS THAT FACILITATES ITS
SPREAD.
JOSEPH PETROZINO WHO IS THE
CHAIR OF MICROBIOLOGY AT BAYLOR
COLLEGE OF MEDICINE, HE SAYS THE
ONE WE HAVE IN THE U.S. SPREADS
BETTER THAN THE ORIGINALLY, THAT
ORIGINALLY EMERGED IN CHINA.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR HOUSTON,
FOR THE HOUSTON AREA,
POTENTIALLY FOR THE COUNTRY?
>> IT MEANS IT’S EASIER FOR THE
DISEASE TO SPREAD AND FOR MORE
PEOPLE TO GET INFECTED.
PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY IS MASKING UP WHEN
THEY’RE OUT IN PUBLIC.
PEOPLE NEED TO SOCIALLY DISTANCE
FROM PEOPLE THAT AREN’T IN THEIR
HOMES.
IF WE DON’T, WE’RE GOING TO LOSE
CONTROL OF THE VIRUS.
YOU SEE WHAT’S ALREADY HAPPENED
IN TEXAS.
WE HAD A PRETTY GOOD GRIP ON IT
EARLIER ON IN THE PANDEMIC IN
APRIL AND GOING INTO MAY, UNTIL
WE REOPENED OUR ECONOMY AT A
BREAKNECK PACE.
ONCE WE DID THAT, CASES STARTED
GOING UP DRAMATICALLY,
INCREASING OVER THE PAST TWO TO
THREE WEEKS ALMOST AT AN
EXPONENTIAL RATE.
NOW WE’RE TRYING TO GET A HANDLE
ON IT AGAIN, TO THE POINT WHERE
THE GOVERNOR HAD TO REISSUE A
MASK ORDER.
THERE WAS A PERIOD OF 67 DAYS
WHERE THE GOVERNOR PROHIBITED
PEOPLE IN HOUSTON FROM ISSUING
OR ISSUINGOUR OWN MASK ORDER UNT
FORCED TO DO IT FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE.
MOLLY:  YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
SUGGESTION THERE SHOULD BE A
NATIONWIDE MASK MANDATE, AS
OPPOSED TO STATE BY STATE.
>> I THINK HEALTHCARE IS BEST
DELIVERED LOCALLY.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS
TRYING TO HAVE DECISIONS MADE BY
LOCAL POLITICIANS AT ALL COSTS,
IF WE CAN.
I THINK IT’S A MISTAKE FOR
SOMEONE TO COME IN AND OVERRULE
WHAT THE LOCAL POLITICIANS WANT
TO DO IF THAT MEANS THEY WANT TO
MASK AND IF IT BECOMES NECESSARY
AS IT BECAME NECESSARY IN TEXAS
FOR THE SAKE OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
WE NEED A MASK ORDER.
WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED ONE
NATIONALLY, I THINK AT THIS
POINT IT SHOULD BE A STATE BY
STATE DECISION.
IF IT’S OVERWHELMING THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY, I WOULD CALL ON THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE THAT ORDER AS
WELL.
MOLLY:  HOUSTON AMONG OTHER
CITIES IN THE SOUTH, AND
ARIZONA, SOME IN FLORIDA HAVE
BEEN DESCRIBED AS HOT SPOTS.
HOW DO YOU CLIMB OUT OF THAT?
WHAT IS THE STRATEGY?
WHAT DO PEOPLE NEED TO DO?
WHAT DO PROVIDERS NEED TO DO,
ALSO THE GOVERNMENT THAT ARE
SPEAKING AND WORKING TO INFORM
THE PEOPLE.
>> I THINK WE NEED CONSISTENT
LEADERSHIP FROM THE TOP DOWN.
AS I SAID BEFORE, I’LL REITERATE
NOW, MASKING, SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND TAKING THE CORONAVIRUS
SERIOUSLY IS WHAT WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO DO.
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO REALIZE IS THAT OUR
TREATMENTS IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
ARE FAIRLY LIMITED.
WE HAVE OXYGEN THAT WE CAN GIVE
TO PATIENTS, ANTI-VIRAL
REMDESIVIR THAT WE CAN GIVE TO
PEOPLE TO SHORTEN HOSPITAL
STAYS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SIMPLE
INTERVENTIONS, SOMETHING AS EASY
AS OXYGEN, HAVE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT HOW MUCH DOES THAT COST
FOR SOMEONE TO ACTUALLY TAKE
CARE OF THAT AT HOME.
I WAS LOOKING UP, HOW MUCH IS AN
OXYGEN CONCENTRATOR, IT’S ON THE
ORDER OF HUNDREDS TO UP TO
$3,000 FOR THAT MACHINE.
WHAT DO YOU DO IN TEXAS WHERE
YOU HAVE 18% OF THE POPULATION
UNINSURED.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE THAT NEED SUCH A
SIMPLE THERAPY HAVE ACCESS TO
IT.
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY RIGHT NOW IS
WE HAVE A MORAL IMPERATIVE TO
ONE ANOTHER TO ADDRESS THINGS
LIKE THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH, THINGS LIKE
UNININSURANCE SO PEOPLE THAT ARE
SICK CAN GET THE CARE THEY NEED
SO THEY CAN RECOVER AND RETURN
TO BEING FUNCTIONAL MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY.
MOLLY:  DOCTOR DARK, A VERY VERY